hi guys how's it going good nice to meet
you virtually zendaya nice to see you
again virtually john david
john david i'm going to start with you
so malcolm's a little obsessed with
reviews for his movie how are you going
to approach
looking at reviews for malcolm memory
because you're producing both of your
producers on this
uh yeah um well i've learned a lot from
malcolm in that uh
i will i will choose to omit that uh
part of the process and i will not read
these things because uh i see what it
can do to a person
i feel like i have more of my sanity
than he does i feel like i'm
a lot calmer than he is so i probably
could handle it
better than he could anyway right
and today people are going to eat their
words all those people those silly
people that are saying they can't see
you in adult roles you're absolutely
incredible in this but like say prior to
euphoria like was it an issue for you
at all in terms of being considered for
adult roles or was it a pretty seamless
transition for you well i just like to
take my time
you know i i i'd like to to just kind of
take my time and and
with that takes you know you have to
there's a lot of no's as well as
you know as much probably if not more
than the yeses you know so
um i i just uh when it i guess i guess i
understand it a little bit because i
have been playing 16 since i was 16.
um right and you know thankfully uh
black don't crack so i'm i i probably
sometimes you know look look a bit young
but uh
but i but i am you know a grown woman
and so it's you know this was special to
me not only because it was written for
me
but i think it was also written to me
and the woman that i you know i'm
growing into and i think that was hugely
what marie kind of turned out to be
while sam was writing um
and it's special when a character is
written for us you know these are
you know this is who he thought of as he
was writing it and we were able to be a
part of that process from the beginning
you know and
being able to talk with him you know for
hours after you know
you know he'd write pages we'd talk
about it for like however long and
um i mean it it really is a special
experience you know
unlike anything i've been a part of um
and to that degree so um yeah i'm i'm
very
i'm i'm grateful you know for the whole
process and i couldn't
have asked for a better world to kind of
take that step yeah absolutely so john
david so your sister is also a producer
on this right
yes and then i noticed that your mom got
a special thanks in the credits
why was that yeah why was that oh that's
so cool of you to mention yeah she did
um i uh i mean why not you know what i'm
saying
that's true yeah true i'm a producer
yeah
but like let me personally though
there's a i just love um
when i first you know so when i read
scripts i i immediately give them to my
mom after i read it and uh
i remember her reaction i'll never
forget it when i when she read the
script for the first time she
she was done and she looks up at me and
says sam wrote this
and uh you know there's something to be
said that uh she got the the seal of
approval and that uh we were
we were making something special so um
just the encouragement and the love and
um
and all that stuff so uh and yeah i'm a
producer so why not should i do
myself who are producing them yeah
that's true yeah that's true
so yeah so i know you guys are both
gonna be part of the celebration of
black cinnamon a few weeks you're
getting an award there but
what's it been like for you though like
so you just went through the emmys
getting an emmy at home now you guys
both be part of the award season so
what's
what's this like remote award season
experience like is it just totally
weird um i've never really experienced
it
other than this you know right with all
this so i've
i've only ever experienced it in in
this new virtual way so i think probably
john david can speak
that a little better because i just all
i know now
yeah is it weird john david um i guess
i'm just used to
come coming from the tenant um press
tour
and and doing all that it just feels
like the you know it's just an extension
of that
and um so i mean it's it's comfortable
like you know i
it's been pretty nice uh yeah i think
it's cool just to talk about the film
and
however you know in this form i would
like to get people to see people in
person obviously and i would love for it
to be in theaters
but uh still you know this is it's cool
i don't mind it yeah
yeah but both you're absolutely amazing
congratulations and zendaya that gq
cover
is absolutely incredible congratulations
guys thank you have a great day
you